il a fait l'objet de nombreuses études
et de rapports par des experts
internationaux sur son efficacité
elle est aujourd'hui on mollo gay dans
pas moins de 71 pays à travers la
planète mais rien n'y fait levêque sens
unique les toujours affublée de
lancement adjectif controversé dans
certains médias français un nouveau
rapport du ministère de la santé de
saint marin constate pourtant une
efficacité du vaccin russe de 80% de six
à huit mois après la deuxième dose ce
qui n'a visiblement pas emule agence
européenne des médicaments qui selon
reuters ne prévoit toujours pas de
l'homologuer cette année estimant qu'il
manquerait encore des documents avant sa
mise sur le marché le taux alors que
l'épidémie repart de plus belle dans le
vieux continent mais reste une lueur
d'espoir puisque l'organisation mondiale
de la santé elle promet désormais la
certification de spoutnik mais pour le
mois de décembre
il est peu probable que le régulateur
européen des médicaments prennent la
décision d'approuver ou non le vaccin
russe contre le coc vide 19 le spoutnik
v avant au moins le 1er trimestre 2011
22 car il manque toujours certaines
données nécessaires pour l'examen du
côté de l'institut gamaleya concepteur
du vaccin on a de plus en plus de mal à
dissimuler son mécontentement alexandre
gainsboug à son directeur pour un
notamment du doigt la mauvaise foi des
bureaucrates dont est victime le vaccin
russe il y a en ce moment une très
grande concurrence autour des flux
financiers dans le monde à la fois entre
les différents fabricants de vaccins et
indirectement entre les pays où ces
sociétés pharmaceutiques au pair en même
temps on ne peut pas dire que la
législation européenne soient harmonisés
avec la législation russe il y à un
certain nombre de problèmes qui
apparaissent précisément à cause de
cette incohérence et cela mène à des
retards
si un vaccin était reconnue en fonction
des résultats de son utilisation
pratique le processus serait plus rapide
la campagne de vaccination a montré que
spoutnik vais pas un parfaitement à
protéger le corps contre une large gamme
de souche de coronavirus cependant les
responsables de l'uem a est en partie de
l' oms ne veulent pas le voir en russie
en attendant on vient d'enregistrer le
vaccin pour les adolescents de 12 à 18
ans sous le nom de spoutnik m en outre
les autorités viennent de donner leur
feu vert pour les recherche d'un remède
destiné aux enfants à partir de 2 ans
vladimir poutine lui-même a testé le
vaccin sous sa forme nasale encore en
phase d'élaboration
exactement six mois après la vaccination
mais niveau d'anticorps ont baissé et
les spécialistes m'ont recommandé une
revaccination que j'ai fait il ya
plusieurs jours d'abord je me suis fait
vacciner et le lendemain après une
consultation avec denis aurait beach en
fait c'est lui qui a fait la deuxième
partie de la procédure je parle de ce
médicament sous forme de poudre à
prendre par voie nasale qu'est ce que
c'est
c'était la même seringue mais au lieu
d'une substance liquide il a pris une
poudre m'a demandé de prendre une grande
respiration en comptant jusqu'à 3 alpes
ulvé risée le médicament d'un côté de
l'autre j'ai attendu la 15e minute et
c'était fini
je n'ai ressenti aucune douleur pour
être honnête aucune je suis resté assis
pendant 15 minutes après ces deux
procédures l'injection et la forme
nasale j'ai déjà fait du sport
aujourd'hui
selon une étude de chercheurs argentins
qui ont testé différentes combinaisons
de vaccins les meilleurs résultats sont
obtenus par un tandem composé de vaccins
adénovirus et arn par exemple scouts
nick v avec modern à
l'analyse préliminaire a donné des
résultats positifs tant en matière
d'innocuité qu'en termes
d'immunogénicité dans les schémas
thérapeutiques hétérologue mise en
oeuvre dans le cadre du plan stratégique
de vaccination contre le coronavirus en
argentine de leur côté les pays
européens dont la france depuis ce jeudi
se pressent pour administrer la
troisième dose du vaccin dans un
contexte de flambée épidémique
cette énième retard pour la
certification de spoutnik les amène à se
poser la question suivante les intérêts
des populations sont elles réellement au
coeur des considérations des
fonctionnaires de l'union européenne